it is the worst when cops pull you over
just to get your number it's like I kind
of beat God this chicks like obsessed
with me she won't leave me alone
I mean it's like great that he has a big
dick and everything but like oh it is so
hard to walk the next day like oh those
are so busy and exhausted ever since
they promoted me I did my interview for
this job
so hung over and I still you should use
my cabin in Aspen I'm barely ever there
and I hate that it sits empty mostly
I've been sticking to this diet for four
weeks now and I'm like really seeing
results but oh I'm like so hungry
look so gross my skin's peeling from
when I was on the beach in Honolulu oh I
get pulled over so much more now that I
have my BMW it is crazy
I spend my entire Sunday in a hot tub so
I'm really dehydrated this guy I met on
Saturday said the craziest thing he was
like oh my god you're so cute I'm like
usually gay but for you I would totally
be straight sorry if I seem out of it
today last night I saw Drake at a bar
here just buying shots shopping sucks do
you know how hard it is to find an
extra-small tinder is stupid at a point
right because you just keep swiping
right it's just like match match match
match match I'm just like what is the
point of tinder anymore like I can't
talk to all of you